foreign
[Music]
so if you came here to attend erc216
you're in the right room
if you came here to attend something
else you're still in the right room stay
here feel free to comment come up in
front if you want
um
my name is called Steve Doss most folks
call me KD simply just go by that I'll
be joined by solil Surrey
and over the next 45 minutes
we will go through a number of different
announcements and and topics in
particular so let's go to talk about
Innovations and announcements in making
our infrastructure portfolio uh richer
for your use
Chris is going to talk about operations
automation security and compliance and
then we'll hear from a customer
okay throughout
this event and throughout our
interaction with you you'll hear us talk
about how we optimize for workloads for
your workloads and we firmly believe
that the best infrastructures that which
is finely tuned and optimized for your
workload they may be AIML workloads
modern workloads
other workloads that you have
and through this we focus on core
priorities of making this infrastructure
reliable or making the Constructor
secure cost efficient simple and
sustainable
but the reason
we embarked on the Journey of cloud
and the reason Google in particular
shines is because of the bottom piece
which is this unique platform
Innovations
that make our infrastructure shine those
are around custom silicon that we build
it's around Cloud systems that are built
for scale
and around AI driven automation that
makes the lives of our customers you all
better
thank you
but today in particular we're going to
talk about four ways in which we help
you
run high performance workloads
run them cost effectively
leverage tools and automation to
optimize their operations
and finally Safeguard the cloud through
security and compliance
Okay so
start with and you'll hear this in the
first section with salil there's this
tension between
uncompromising performance
and cost
running high performance compute
workloads are super important
but they're not always important for all
workloads there are workloads which need
to optimize for call for efficiency for
costs and we will talk about how our
portfolio allows you to balance the
trade-offs more effectively
the second piece is around running the
cloud optimizing operations and we talk
about a number of different tools that
help you do that Chris will cover these
about flexmix future reservations
an equivalent code component
and then finally we have a
very unique and differentiated approach
to to security to compliance
Chris is also going to cover a number of
different Innovations in that space
around confidential Computing assured
workloads and our unique approach to
compliance
so lots to cover so without the further
Ado I will welcome salil up on the stage
salil
there you go take it away
okay live thank you for coming to our
talk today uh thanks Katie
so as Katie mentioned uh we're going to
sort of cover our compute portfolio and
go deeper into the choices that are sort
of available to you as our customers
so customers such as yourself like have
had a few conversations since today
morning and like are looking to build
modern new applications using the best
that the cloud has to offer
but at the same time you don't want to
sort of forget traditional Enterprise
workloads which for many of you form the
vast majority of your ID landscape right
so at Google Cloud our mission is to
purpose build infrastructure
to account for needs of all of your
workloads and our compute portfolio
reflects that
so our general purpose offerings are
designed to span a wide cross-section of
workloads like I would I would Hazard
like up to 90 of the workloads that you
have in your data center could be sort
of classified as general purpose
and there is but we have a bunch of
different offerings in there and each of
these offerings are designed to sort of
give you some amount of optimizations
balancing for cost
maximum flexibility as well as extreme
consistent performance
our specialized VM offerings on the
other hand are purpose built to design
to sort of give you maximum performance
for a given resource type and a resource
type here being compute so if you really
need like a high clock speed like CPU
or memory so you need like memory ratios
like really high memory for sap Hana
kind of workloads
or gpus for your aim applications
and today
let me share with you some announcements
that we're making and updates that we're
making to our portfolio
first the sea family is sort of getting
a makeover right so C Used to Be compute
optimized with the launch of C3 and its
shift to general purpose we are
signaling its broad applicability to a
broad cross-section of workloads much
more than what it before
this family is optimized for great
performance and minimal disruptions to
your workloads and this is think of it
as a great family for workloads that do
not write any performance variants while
running
we do all this while also delivering
industry leading storage and network
performance and we'll talk about that in
the subsequent slides
you might be wondering what is C family
good for which workloads map on to see
family
and like I said it's for a general
purpose offering so it's a broad swath
of your workloads typically customers
run end user facing applications these
are applications which are Revenue
critical for your business these are
applications which are low latency and
they show up in the form of databases
caches streaming workloads Network
appliances
and such
cvms are also the first set of DMS that
are based on the newest elements of
Google Cloud titanium architecture as
you heard from Thomas today hopefully
some of you made it to the keynote uh
titanium is our custom
purpose-built dedicated Hardware stack
that offloads the CPU and provides
performance reliability scale and
security improvements for your Cloud
workloads this is great because this
frees up the CPU to focus on customer
workloads and maximizing the performance
for customer workloads
the new titanium architecture also comes
designed to transparently handle
infrastructure updates so while we
update our infrastructure in the
background there is absolutely zero
disruption to your workloads which is
amazing
Google's new custom built infrastructure
Processing Unit or ipu which is part of
our titanium architecture allows us to
offload the networking from you know the
host onto a dedicated network card
option
so which is which is which allows us to
sort of achieve like staggering results
let's take a look at what our customer
Expo Gio was able to achieve
X which I O designs an extremely high
performance layer 3 switch designed
specifically for broadcast media and
financial streaming services customers
they were able to sort of achieve four
and a half times Improvement and
performance and they were they got up to
183 gigabits per second and 30 million
packets per second out of a single VM
instance and we believe that we can go
even higher and we've seen numbers to
that effect
last but not the least
titanium also enhances the security for
your workloads because we are able to do
line rate encryption and much much more
uh enhancing the security profile of
your Cloud workloads running on our
platform
titanium has been underway for many many
years many of the products that you
already use benefit from the titanium
architecture but the newest elements of
titanium are sort of coming we're
bringing them to you in the guise of
cvms and hyperdisc but this is going to
be the foundation of all future Google
Cloud offerings so this is going to be
the under architecture that underpins
all of it
with that let's dive into C3 Google was
first to Market to bring general purpose
VMS based on Intel's fourth generation
Sapphire Rapids uh processor
build on the latest compute storage and
networking Innovations
c3vms offer up to a 35 Better Price
performance than previous generation VMS
while the customers also get 50 faster
access to ddr5 memory as well as AMX
accelerator which is used for CPU ml
inference and is 12x faster than the AVX
512 instruction set
but that's not all
C3 also like I said is based on the
titanium architecture and we are able to
not only improve the packets per second
performance we are also able to
um
achieve 200 gigabits per second
throughput for a single VM instance this
is 2X or previous generation and for
those of you who are not going up to
that high in terms of network bandwidth
consumption we are also doubling the 2x
standard VM bandwidth so without opting
into tier one networking the standard
bandwidth lean scales linearly depending
on the size of the instance all the way
up to 100 gigabits per second which is
twice as much then you can get anywhere
else in public cloud
and last but not the least it gets even
better with hyperdisc because we
announced hyperdisc last year it's our
next Generation block storage
architecture it allows you to truly
decouple storage and compute and
therefore allows you to maximize TCO
savings for your customers and your
workloads
with
it we are able to deliver up to 15x
higher iops and 8x higher throughput
which is in preview right now that
translates to roughly 500k Ops per C3
instance which is again the highest
available to you in public Cloud so this
is great but we're not stopping with C3
I'm super excited to sort of announce
our c3d offering which is sort of right
now in preview based on amd's fourth
generation Genoa processors
c3d combines C families Enterprise grade
reliability and tooling with the
significant boost provided by amd's for
Generation Genoa processors these are
massive machines these are up to 360
vcpus 2.8 terabytes of memory on a whole
host so these which makes them great for
sort of processing large data sets and
we have seen our customers are realizing
anywhere north of like 45 percent gains
price performance relative to our
previous generation AMD VMS and we have
seen great results on a wide variety of
benchmarks such as data processing
in-memory databases relational databases
code compiling workflows
arm that brings me to arm and arm is so
as I talk to customers our customers are
telling us that arm is a great part of
their
infrastructure is strategy and they're
adopting arm increasingly and as we do
that
they're conveying their excitement to us
so today we are super excited to
pre-announce our upcoming c3a BMS based
on ampere processor
and we expect c3a to deliver 40 Better
Price performance relative to comparable
x86 instances in the market
c3a will be available in more regions
with more features with Advanced
networking and will be enabled with up
to hundreds of isv applications right
out of the gate this should really allow
you to sort of you know enable and
enable your workloads on arm and we have
seen some good success with that
Dailymotion is seen great results and I
think it makes for a very cost effective
solution
with these announcements we have a
complete C portfolio across Intel AMD
and arm and we allow an enabled choice
so you can choose what is best for you
and your workloads
when we think about Switching gears when
we think about
making and you know the things that we
need to do to make Google Cloud platform
a great place for researchers scientists
such as yourself to run your HPC
workloads we typically think about three
things first is fast and affordable
infrastructure so that you get those TCO
savings and you have the lowest time to
complete your job
second is easy and compatible our
platform should be easy to use for an
individual researcher as well as in HPC
Guru right and it should be compatible
so that it allows us to sort of plug
into all the partner offerings that we
have out there third is partner
preferred we work very hard to enable a
broad partner ecosystem and that allows
for us to expose that choice back to you
as a customer
we are optimizing our infra capabilities
across compute storage and networking as
an example we recently announced and
this is in preview our H3 VMS hdbms are
purpose built for HPC workloads and
offer up to 3x Improvement in Burn node
performance and up to 2x lower cost than
a previous generation VMS which is
staggering the benefits this benefits
like a wide variety of Industries so
from molecular Dynamics to like weather
forecasting to computational finance
outside of each three we are also making
other improvements to make sure that you
can run HPC workloads in a seamless
Fashion on our platform an example that
I would like to sort of call out is
panel store so palette store is a
managed file system service which went
into preview today and it's built on the
Intel deos OSS stack it's an ex it
provides extreme iops like millions of
iops it provides extreme throughput so
you can think about like 100 gigabits
per second measured at the maximum
capacity and extremely low latency and
it is 6.3 times faster read throughput
performance compared to any other
competitive uh like service offering
available in public Cloud today
so let's go a little bit deeper into H3
H3 offers industry leading performance I
talked about per node performance going
up by 3x and costs coming down but we
also do all this while maintaining high
efficiency for example on a popular
weather forecasting Benchmark we were
able to demonstrate that we can go up to
4000 cores over 4000 cores keeping 90
efficiency which is almost like doubled
in the previous generations
we are extremely pleased to sort of
partner with a wide variety of
ecosystems so rescale alter answers told
CAE parallel Works to actually bring all
of this Innovation into you so that you
can choose the best integration points
for your HPC workloads
with that let me turn it over to Krish
to take you through infrastructure
operations
thanks uh so you heard about the breadth
of the portfolio that we have with
respect to VM families and uh one that
is actually built with a lot of your
workloads in mind it's not a
one-size-fits-all even though the
general purpose for workloads fit into
our general purpose families for the
most part what we'll actually cover
through in the next few minutes is
really how do we manage that growing
portfolio of VMS and the new families
that are coming in in an efficient
secure uh and automated way so we'll
cover through a number of different
topics as we go along that cover all the
way from reliability to security and
everything in between so let's start
with uh reliability
so a good VM portfolio really needs to
deal with all of the different things
that it needs to optimize for the
workload but at the same time it really
needs to be Rock Solid and reliable so
one of the things that we by doing at
Google cloud is investing pretty heavily
into node level reliability so when you
think about that you're really talking
about firmer level reliability you're
thinking about hypervisor level
reliability and sort of overall Machine
level reliability
in total so one of the things that we're
doing is reliability at scale we're very
very happy to announce that we have
upped the bar on overall reliability for
general purpose machines from what used
to be 99.5 percentage to 99.9 so it's a
three nines for all gel purpose uh
machines going forward and on top of
that for memory optimized machines we're
sort of pushing the bar even higher to
99.95 percent reliability so it's 395
reliability going forward so starting
today those two are going to be the new
benchmarks on reliability that we have
industry-wide and one of the other
things that we're doing here is
providing you the information to be able
to go ahead and then monitor the overall
reliability and health off the
environment So within the console today
you now have built-in dashboards that
allow you to observe the overall health
of your environment in a very very easy
way and of course there are apis
available for doing that as well and on
top of that we also add recommendations
and alerts if there are issues that we
actually find with respect to the
overall reliability of the environment
so in total we want to make sure that
the base reliability level you have
really large numbers that you can
actually depend on and provide you the
instrumentation that allows you to go
ahead and then tackle any issues that
happen even past that in a proactive way
talking about proactive
any large Fleet of anything for that
matter whether it's compute machines in
a data center or large fleets of cars
they will need maintenance and we want
to make sure that the active maintenance
or life cycle management does not really
impact your workloads so Google has been
heavily investing historically and even
more so now on a set of technologies
that allow you to do live migration off
your workloads so customers such as Etsy
and aerospike use that pretty heavily in
ensuring that their workloads themselves
do not get disrupted as a result of the
maintenance actions that Google takes
live migration allows you to go ahead
and then move a workload from one
machine to another without disruption
with memory transfer to the data has
actually shows up and the computation
essentially happens without any pause on
top of live migration we also have live
update which allows the actions that we
take for the software stack at the node
level to be done without any disruption
to your workload so live migration takes
care of you know sort of anything that
mitigates the movement of machines from
one to another while live update
essentially does the In-Place updating
off your node software without
disruptions between these two we expect
that a vast majority of what we do from
a maintenance standpoint will actually
be taken care of without any disruption
deal workload but on top of that we're
also providing mechanisms through which
you would actually get much more
proactive notifications for those
situations let's say you've got a large
sap Hana database or you're running a
whole bunch of GPU oriented workloads
for your AIML jobs we want to make sure
that the overall notification period is
long enough in such a way that you'd be
able to go ahead and take actions based
on the fact that there is a future
maintenance event that's coming in and
that's not the last thing we also are
looking to introduce user triggered
maintenance which is really maintenance
happening on your terms on your
schedules so the collection of these
capabilities then allow you to go ahead
and then tackle Fleet Maintenance in a
least disruptive way for your jobs
moving from there we also want to talk a
little bit about flexibility of
provisioning within your environment
so mix we're actually pre-announcing
that here at next
imagine a manage instance Group which is
a way in which you would actually have a
set of homogeneous VMS at very large
scales hundreds if not thousands that
could actually be deployed as one entity
with this new capability we're
introducing two dimensions of
flexibility for these large managed
instance groups one dimension of
flexibility is by VM family so you could
mix and match
different VM families into a single
manage instance group in such a way that
you could go ahead and optimize one part
of that manage instance group for one
type of workload from a price
performance standpoint and another part
is a different price Performance Point
but all being managed as one group or
one entity
the second dimension that we're
introducing is really the consumption
model today when you deploy a managed
instance group it's either all on-demand
workloads or all spot workloads and
neither shell to mix
with this new capability that's coming
in we're actually allowing you to go
ahead and then provide a mix of
consumption models between on-demand and
spot which then allows you to optimize
both on the availability and cost
factors for your particular workloads so
this is going to come into preview
shortly you want to make sure that you
knew this first here
moving from there and talk about
capacity
Cloud capacity is elastic
when you need more capacity you grow
into it when you have less needs you
know you just kind of give it in
somebody else has got that need they
could actually use that and that's kind
of how Cloud capacity works and we all
know that however
there are situations where you have a
critical business need and you need to
make sure that that cloud capacity is
absolutely assured
to be there for you when you need it for
an example let's say you know your photo
room and you've got a very large app
rollout that's coming up and you know
that's going to happen in about a
month's time and you need to make sure
that you're not just depending on the
normal elasticity of the cloud but you
want to have a highly assured capacity
available to you at that time that's
exactly what they do future reservations
is the capability through which we'd
actually provide you that high level of
assurance For an upcoming workload burst
that you might have in the future in
your environment this can be applied to
a variety of use cases clearly a future
burst in workloads is a good one anytime
that you have rare uh Supply constrained
resources that you want to have your
hands on in some future time that's an
excellent place but you could actually
go ahead and use that too you're moving
into a new Data Center and you want to
make sure that that migration is going
to be successful for you and you know
exactly when that move is going to
happen use future reservations and that
allows you to go ahead and then
apportion that capacity for you at no
extra charge so this is a capability
that we're public purviewing today that
then allows you to go ahead and then go
straight into the console and then
create a future reservation for any new
workload that's coming in that you need
burst capacity for sort of additional
capacity for fully assured for you all
of the capacity planning and the
Assurance is taken care of in the back
end and you're able to go ahead and then
enjoy using this capacity at the time
that you need for your most critical
workloads
moving from there we want to talk a
little bit about Job management how many
of you were at the keynote and then
heard the word Ai and have a word count
quite a few right so a lot of the AI
jobs essentially end up being large
batch jobs
so I've got a model training work that's
going on or I have some inference job
that's going on that's a lot of itty
bitty workloads that are all combined
together to form one giant workload
what Google batch allows you to do is to
essentially act as a funnel as a managed
service that allows you that collection
of workloads to be brought in into one
entity the Google back service and then
execute it from there we have a number
of different Partnerships that we've
built over time and continuing to build
and invest into where whether it's life
sciences whether it's finops whether
it's core AIML workloads or any others
or HPC type of workloads as you know
salil is talking about with the H3 VMS
you'd be able to go ahead and then bring
all of those together into a single
entry point that is fully managed for
you from a job subjunction standpoint
from a job Control job notification and
job assembly perspective so Google batch
is available in production for you to
tackle all of those challenges as you go
forward
very excited to talk about a particular
particular that is really really sweet
for Developers
how many times did you have to actually
go in and then do something in a console
and just wished that you could simply
automate the 15 clicks or 20 clicks that
you did to go ahead and then take that
one action
we're debuting equivalent code component
that's available in production on the
cloud console today that allows you to
Simply do exactly that you're able to go
ahead and then take a series of UI
actions and have those UI actions
parametrically convert into code that
you could use right away
and that code would be available in a
variety of form factors you could use
that as rest API you could use that as
terraform you could use that as our
gcloud CLI all of those are available
for any of those actions that you would
take on the console for a series of
things
developers dream because now I could
take that one set of actions that I do
on the UI and simply go ahead and then
parametrically automate that to n number
of times that I want to do embed that in
my scripts embed that into my automation
Frameworks and go from there
moving from there I want to talk a
little bit about security and compliance
so today Kevin mandia and Thomas Korean
in the keynote kind of highlighted a
number of different things that are
happening from an overall security
standpoint at Google but here in the
next few minutes we'll talk a little bit
about some of the things that we're
doing from a compute standpoint
the first thing is really about
integrity of your environment
confidential Computing is not new but
what we're continuing to do with it is
we partner very heavily with two of our
major Partners AMD for their secure
encrypted virtualization or Sev
technology that allows you to
essentially have signature driven
hardware-controlled
signatures that you could actually
tackle at the firmer level and up above
at the host software level that allows
you to go ahead and then have a clear
view of what that software is any change
that actually gets done for that
software and be able to secure that
environment at the lowest level possible
we're also expanding that in the C3
platform that cilia talked about earlier
with Intel's trusted domain extension
technology again very similar from a
hardware perspective that allows you to
go ahead and then get that utmost
Integrity for that node going forward so
confidential computing
compliance is a huge
factor for many many of our workloads
not necessarily for U.S government or
some other governmental needs but even
for our industry needs whether it's
HIPAA whether it's PCI whether it's nebs
or any other industry level compliance
one of the approaches that Google has
taken in this is not necessarily
sequester or ask you to sequester your
compliance needed workloads into some
corner like a gov cloud
we've taken a different approach in
providing you the controls that you need
on our regular data centers in such a
way that you're not really operating
with a smaller set of services on some
sequester gov Cloud but you're operating
with the broadest set of services on our
general purpose public cloud data
centers with the right controls that you
could actually go ahead and apply to
them
we're very proud to say that a short
workloads which is the mechanism through
which you would actually do those
controls is now available in nine
regions today and is continuing to
expand this is the largest set of
Regulatory Compliance workloads that you
could actually deploy in any public
Cloud today and the number nine is today
and like I said you know it continues to
expand as we go forward
this provides you a view in terms of the
variety of compliance regulations that
we invest into both in terms of
industry-wide privacy and governmental
and Sovereign requirements that we deal
with you know across so you will see a
number of different Global ISO standards
that we actually comply with today at
the infrastructure level and a number of
specific
country or jurisdiction specific
standards that we comply with as well
and this list is something that will
continue to grow
so from an operations Automation and
security standpoint we continue to
invest pretty heavily into ensuring that
you could go ahead and then utilize
Google cloud in the most efficient and
cost effective way as possible with that
I would love to
invite Mahmoud who is representing snap
he is the engineering manager at snap
that is responsible for the
infrastructure thank you so much
okay hi everyone my name is Mahmoud and
I'm an engineering manager at snap and
today I'll quickly give you an
introduction on how we at snap work with
the Google folks to try to figure out
how we use all those like machines and
innocence types
um so my team I lead the infrastructure
team in snap and my team uh worked with
a lot of snap Engineers that run
different workloads uh some of them are
like reverse proxies some of them are
stateless Services some of them are data
intensive or like machine learning uh
workloads that requires a lot of
computation and then I work with all
these teams to try to figure out what is
the right instance types for them to use
um how we do this uh we usually try to
experiment and measure as much as
possible because every use case is
different so we try to work with them
especially when there's a new machine
type that comes out we try to run it on
like an A B tested and run on different
machine types and see if the performance
is getting better or getting worse and
so on and so forth and then there's some
general guidelines that we've learned by
working with Google for a long time for
example uh C types are very good for
high computation use cases but also use
cases that requires uh stable
performance if this makes sense versus
maybe a more General n-types that are
also high performance but does not have
this uh strong consistent performance uh
machine types like T machine types are a
good for certain workloads that require
specific CPU to memory ratio for example
uh and then there's always like that
performance versus cost trade-off right
sometimes you want to use like the best
machines out there no matter how much
it's gonna cost you and then other cases
you would like try to save cost as much
as possible without compromising
performance
uh and I want to talk about like two use
cases here that looks similar but also
like we have some differences and tell
you how we go about like picking the
right instance types for them uh the
first one is our API Gateway uh those
are like front-end fleets uh that sits
around the world and they talk to our
customers right away so all the Snapchat
users talk to those API gateways and
those are like reverse proxies they
receive HTTP requests they do some maybe
encryption some validation and then
route the request to the right back-end
service and as you could imagine those
are uh very compute intensive use cases
but also the important part is it
requires a very consistent performance
because we don't want to provide
different experience to different users
and in those cases uh machine type like
the C Machine type that has performance
consistency is very important to us
another use case would be the machine
learning those are also like back-end
Services they run feature extraction
training models so also very very heavy
on computation and requires a lot of CPU
but in this case we might be able to
like not really need this performance
consistency and uh in order to be able
to save cost and for these use cases for
example as using something like the N uh
instance types would be very beneficial
because this might be cheaper
and the last thing I want to add is uh
this is a continuous process that we
always work with the Google Engineers as
more machines comes out for example when
the C3 came out and we like tried to
test that we sold as as high of a
performance Improvement as 20 percent
looking forward and I I want to tell you
like this is my last slide so I want to
tell you uh what my team do working with
Google like on a regular basis right the
first thing is capacity planning
um as you mentioned about like future
reservation is like one thing that you
could use in Snapchat for example we
have like some like if there's like a
very popular event usually like around
New Year's Eve we know everyone is going
to pull their phone and start taking
pictures for fireworks for example right
so if you know ahead that there's going
to be a traffic surge you could try to
estimate it and try to work with with
Google or using future reservation to be
able to make sure that you have enough
capacity that you need
um the other two things I think those
are the things that I talked about
trying to uh
find the right balance between
performance reliability and also cost so
if you have like a background services
or a service that would run in the
background does not need a lot of
performance so you'd have to use like a
cheaper instances types versus if you
have something that is maybe user facing
you want to provide consistent
performance as much as possible you want
it to be as fast as possible so you
would use things like C Machine types
there's also things like the Plaid
maintenance if you have use cases that
does not cannot afford being interrupted
for example in this case you might look
at instance types that would provide
more uh predictable maintenance schedule
uh the last thing uh fade over I think
this is also very important as much as
that I would like to think of the cloud
as elastic and has infinite resources uh
and practical this is actually not the
case and there's been a lot of cases
where we try to scale using a certain
instance type and there's just we run
out of them there is not more of them
right so you also when you're designing
this you have to think about okay if I'm
using S3 and there is no more S3 what am
I going to fail over to right and the
last thing you want to do is to fill
over to a machine type that is
drastically different from your main
machine type because now you're having
two different Hardware running your
service which might just completely like
make you making make you reason about
like things like latency very hard right
because some of them are going to be
slow and some of them are going to be
fast it's going to be almost impossible
for you to figure out that the problem
is coming from having different Hardware
right so trying to figure out what kind
of instance type you want to fall over
to in case of your run out of your NSS
type is also very important
uh that's it